welcome to the last Talk of the stage
today so today we're going to talk about
rethinking codes of conduct
um a little bit of disclaimer about this
talk it's uh
this is not a coding talk so it's not
about there's no so much scientific
information that I can vouch for mostly
it's about
opinions and
my opinions
and other people's opinions so don't
like if you disagree that's totally fine
um
Okay so
Let's uh yeah so this is a
an old painting that I found Okay so
oops
no I did okay so yeah about me
so my pronouns are she heard you can
reach me at hello at terrace.com
um this is the picture of a Meetup we
had with the diversity and inclusion
work group with the python software
Foundation
that in part of I am head of data
science Edna official we do data science
boot camps and I'm also offering
leadership coaching so if you need an
inclusive leadership coaching
I'm organizer of the pi ladies Hamburg I
am on the board of the Python software
for band which is running this
conference
and I'm also part of the code of conduct
work group and the diversity and
inclusion
work groups of the Python software
Foundation
and because I have a lot of free time I
am also part of the disk committee which
is a diversity and inclusion in
scientific Computing with non-focus
group
and I also do art stuff and knit under
the TLP up label which don't ask what it
means so a lot of hats
let's say I don't get bored and I wasn't
planning on giving this talk here today
but some speakers uh decided they
couldn't make it anymore so here I am
so first question who here is
contributing to open source by this
definition
you're contributing you're writing bug
reports your maintainers
cool okay what about the invisible work
who here is contributing to open source
according to this additional definition
working in education educating other
people supporting people governance
spreading the work organizing
conferences volunteering at conferences
already we see that all the people with
a green t-shirt they obviously
contribute to open source because you
have a volunteer or organizer swag so
yeah
some people say that the glue of all
this open source working out and
surviving is the community behind that
so why do we like python this is a 2017
quote from Brett Cannon I came here for
the language but I stayed for the
community
and
this was a picture taken at pycon 2017
and people already posted that on
t-shirts so a few yeah
a little bit of a short history of
python according to me of course from a
German perspective so there's a lot of
stuff happening in Python so I'm not
gonna go there but in case you didn't
know in 1991 Guido from Rossum released
first
python version I don't know it was
python one or something anyway then I
think in 2001 the python software
Foundation was formed
so it's quite late then in 2003 we had
the first pycon us which is happening
started now so it's they are they having
a 20 years anniversary
in 2004 the python software fairband the
one that is
financing and running this conference
was formed and it had a funny name that
nobody remembers I mean some people
remember but I don't remember so I think
somebody nods in the back that so he
knows I also just found out the name
this week because they had to rename it
because it was a funny name
in 2011 we had the first pycon de in
Leipzig I think so um
quite a long time ago anybody here was
there wow okay that's cool
so yeah then what happened in 2012 Nam
Focus gets created so python D is older
than non-focus and in 2013 the psf
announces its first code of conduct
so quite a lot of stuff happened before
code of conduct came on uh you know in
play in 2018 around 2018
Sage sharp author Technologies updated
the python software Foundation code of
conduct
um
why I'm mentioning this is because at
the moment the python software
Foundation code of conduct is one of the
better written codes of conducts out
there
and I will talk today a little bit about
why that matters so why do we need a
code of conduct so why did python
software Foundation needed the code of
conduct so this is a link you can scan
it it's a Blog
um
on the psf side
basically it was voted as they felt so
10 years ago so the psf code of conduct
is going to be 10 years old today this
year it was voted because they felt they
were unbalanced and not seeing the true
spectrum of the Greater Community and
thought that with the time with time
they could Advance towards a more
diverse representation
so this is what we wanted 10 years ago
exercise now because some of us we're
like I don't why do we should we care
about codes of conduct right like I mean
everything is fine nothing happened
today everything was well usually
nothing bad happens but let's think of
situations so who here can think of a
situation you had a conflict or tension
with another person
you know like
it can be at work can be in the python
community in another python Community
there's a lot of type in general yeah
think of a situation where someone wrote
or spoke using language that made you
feel uncomfort unwelcome
yeah
think about a situation where you felt
you were stereotyped based on your
perceived demographics
yeah
okay this is a hard one you were stalked
or harassed
yeah so
question number one to think about it
did you tell someone
yeah some people said did you report it
some people report it yeah
was it easy to talk about it
no okay
let's do the other side of the coin
think of a situation where someone had a
conflict or tension with you
yeah it happens to the best of us I mean
we can be on both sides of the coin you
wrote or spoke using a language that
made someone feel unwelcome
him
use stereotype based on perceived
demographics
talking
please don't
yeah so um let's uh yeah so but the
questions here come on the other side
were you able to receive feedback
elegantly
yeah it's uncomfortable right it's like
someone comes and tells you hey you're
an and you're like what I'm
yeah did you find it easy to
understand what you did wrong
because in our you know inner mirror you
know our mirror shows us as perfect
people and then comes someone that says
you're not perfect and it shutters our
universe okay
so
we may at any given point in time be on
any side of the coin it's just because
we are all different and it's really
hard to you know you don't grow up in
other people's shoes
and they don't grow up in your shoes and
it's like takes a lot of lifetime of
learning how to you know identify other
people's shoes
and why does it matter because who is
contributing to open source so this is a
map like the geography of open source
for uh from I think it's a
GitHub survey
and
even though it looks like there's a lot
of people in the United States
contributing to open source at per
capita level also Germany is not doing
that bad
um
so our python Community is global very
few of us had a global upbringing in
education I don't know how many of us
moved to five countries by the time we
were 16.
because that would mean like a global
upbringing to like really go somewhere
else have different people change so so
we grew up in like little bubbles right
most all of us
humans learned their whole life about
other humans and cultures and we need to
accept that we don't know everything
about everybody like a lot of us is
hidden and we don't just go to a new
stranger and just tell us our life story
to them in like instantly right so
and we need to just keep learning and
get better so in my opinion a code of
conduct can be a framework to help us to
really communicate globally in a
successful way
this but it's not like something that
you know you get it right the first time
it's like oh I read the code of conduct
I can now apply it it takes practice it
takes you know one thing to learn
the psf code of conduct has this um
quote I was saying that it's one of the
better written so the python Community
is made of members from around the globe
with diverse diverse set of skills
personalities and experience
and when we're working together this
code of conduct will help us steer your
interactions and keep python a positive
successful and growing community
and we want basically code of conducts
to to encode core values and Norms in
the community for example impressivity
respectfulness and being open and
considerate and provide us provide
guidance to newcomers
and it can also signal to marginalize
people that the open source Community
cares
that also means that when there is no
code of conduct the other signal gets
sent right so
and yeah so let's talk a little bit
about
is our code of conduct working or not
how can you tell that your code of
conduct is not working
well
according to the Linux Foundation survey
the diversity and inclusion survey from
these were the reporting statistics so
apparently like I don't know over 50
percent so yeah no this is not a good
not a very good graph but anyways so a
lot of people reported lack of response
um
or rejection of contributions and
questions so in the code of conduct with
the psf we get a lot of reports about
somebody dismissed my issue and just
closed the issue and didn't listen to me
and so this is happening right conflict
or interpersonal tension between you and
another contributor
written or spoken language that made
people feel unwelcome stereotyping
threats of violence talking unsolutely
unsolicited sexual advances or comments
impersonation or malicious publication
of personal personal information
so whenever we have statistics that say
within this amount of time we didn't
receive any reports so everything is
going on fine
that is not what the data says that the
distribution what's going on out there
right so so this is an actually should
be a flag if you don't have reports
doesn't it doesn't mean that everything
is going fine it actually means that
people don't feel safe to report people
don't feel that it's worth reporting
people are not able to report people are
not able to have a positive conversation
so why why don't people
report so these are some things that
I've noticed I've noticed poorly written
code of conduct
when the code of conduct is written
badly
you end up spending like over an hour
just reading through all the links and
the documentation of the website to find
out if your issue what happened to you
is a code of conduct situation
then you're like so unsure and then in
the end you're even doubting yourself
and then you're like I don't is this
this is and then by the time you're done
reading you think you're imagining
everything that happened to you so
so it's like hard to identify your
situation itself and the statement on
the code of conduct are going to be
vague
which when they are dealing with your
issue
it a lot of things will be up for
interpretation I don't know did anybody
here in the room feel like this happened
to them they reported something
somewhere and in the end
it was like
yeah I don't know it didn't violate
anything or it's like
you're imagining it or something like
that so so this can be really
frustrating and it will take a lot of
effort on the person who reports to
report and that's usually people give up
reporting
another thing that I've noticed is that
many times code of conduct in events
especially in events because these are
like appearing that are happening you
know and then they don't happen anymore
right
the code of conduct can be treated as a
technicality
so we have to have a code of conduct ah
yeah we have to add it to the website
otherwise otherwise some people will
complain and then they do it for these
reasons
some people say like like I'm not going
to attend an event if there does
put a code of conduct somebody complain
so
there's ways to like not have that you
know like I think with Pilates meetups
we usually at every event at the
beginning of the Meetup we talk about
code of conduct it happened also at this
conference at the opening session there
was talk about the code of conduct was
explained everybody was on there now
theoretically is on the same page about
our expectations of behavior at this
conference
Okay so
another thing code of conduct is
perceived as annoying
like this annoying must have something
that gets forgotten added at the end an
afterthought and no enforcing committee
is set so we have a code of conduct
but we don't do anything with it
it turns out that 30 of the people who
filled in that the survey from the Linux
Foundation diversity and inclusion
survey are unsure
codes of conduct will be enforced
that is a big number that means
like there's just no process even to the
people that have ever applied they don't
even get an email at the end it's like
oh we got your report thank you we are
dealing with this or this dialogue that
puts people at ease didn't happen
another thing what I've noticed is
conflicts of interest
you may actually have people in the code
of conduct committee that are the ones
whom the report is about
you know like when you have like older
communities where the founders of the
communities are wearing too many hats
they are in the also in the code you
know like and you know there's just lack
of change and you know the world is
changing but some people don't change
and then they're everywhere and you
can't complain anymore because they
would get the report and how can you
even report if you know that the person
who's you're reporting about is in the
committee or friends of the people right
so
and this is something that people who
are like in a code of conduct committee
and end up recusing themselves at every
meeting because oh I can't have an
opinion about this person I can't say my
opinion about this person because we're
friends and I know and we contributed to
code together and I can't say anything
and if you recuse yourself most of the
time then why are you in that committee
you want to be in a committee go to
another community and to the code of
conduct committee
and another thing that's happening and
this is why I'm having this talk also to
rethink about code of conduct it's like
people in the community some people not
of course not everybody there are some
people that think that the role of the
code of conduct is to be the police
and
and I mean
just call it a generation divide call it
it can be all sorts of reasons why this
is happening but this has happening even
in the python software Foundation where
the code of conduct committee doesn't
have any power we only recommend actions
to the steering Council we don't
actually kick people off the mailing
list we don't ban people from
contributing to python
but this is not really understood by the
general uh python developer community
and we did get I've seen application to
the steering Council where the text of
the application was I will remove some
of the power that the code of conduct
committee has because we have now lost
some very
experts who are contributing and then
they got kicked out because of their
behavior you know like
and again so if you have a good process
you know like we don't have the power to
do that we just you know like
um recommend
we wouldn't really lose this power this
is like
um this power doesn't exist anyway to be
lost in the first place
so how can we get our codes of conduct
working
so here I have like
um
the part about
writing the code of conduct the text
itself and enforcing the code of conduct
so these are two things I think that are
the two so the writing code of conduct
from what I've seen is first you have
the values right the values of the
community are explicitly mentioned and
they represent the members in the
community now think about of all the
companies I don't know how many of you
work in a company
do you have values defined in your
company
top down bottom up I don't know you know
there's always Mission Vision you know
sometimes it's room for improvement in
some companies but and also in some
communities so these values if they're
like not transparent that they exist
then how can people like even you know
use those
so this is basically these are the
values of the Python software Foundation
code of conduct
being open considerate respectful and
then they're also explained then in the
end this whole code of conduct
definition you can like come back to it
and then see if any of these values you
feel like got like
um crossed
the second part about writing the code
of conduct is defining the norms and
standards like what are the behaviors
that are acceptable and what are the
behaviors that are not acceptable
how do you deal with those you know
what's the process so here there are
plenty of good examples out there nobody
today is writing from scratch their code
of conduct I mean that would be like
you know it's like it's a lot of work
and it's a lot of collaborative work
that all of the codes of conduct out
there are at the moment like
um licensed that everybody can use so
they are on free licenses because this
is something that everybody wants
everybody to get better at so
there's zero reason for this not to be
used yeah
so the again from the python software
Foundation again there's a whole list of
what's inappropriate
and it's really easy to say like if this
you know
if you like stalking is there you know I
don't have to think about it like I got
followed I don't want to be followed I
um
logging it's like
dog saying is public you know having uh
language violin language directed
against another person so all of these
things are there's the list is longer
this is just a screenshot so all of
these things are described explicitly
and it's also then easy for you to say
okay this was not inclusive
um okay so now let's remember the
situations where I remember at the
beginning of the talk we were talking
about the situations
so ideally this code of conduct how it
is defined should be helping you with
talking about the situations you as a
person reporting it it should help you
better understand
what Behavior
you know putting it in words to explain
what was not acceptable about what
happened to you but also if you are on
the other side you know to understand
that
um you can also think about what are the
values a lot of times you need to talk
about your feelings and then you're like
it's really hard to pinpoint exactly
what was that feeling what happened to
me
and
and then it's also something that
validates because a lot of the times
when something happens to us we are
unsure like how many times did something
happen to you and then you went for a
second opinion to ask whether this was
really like do you really think this
like am I in the right should I feel
offended about this or am I like you
know sensitive and
yeah so
this should be with a proper code of
conduct you shouldn't need to ask
another person for
um saying that yes you're right you know
because our society is teaching us that
no we are not right so the code of
conduct is there to help
okay and then comes the second part
enforcement
so you have to think about codes of
conducts
are a glass Roots movement they were
they were not like top-down like the sea
level Something decided they want to
code of conduct it was mostly the people
the community self-regulated and said we
need to Define our guidelines
and
and we need to say if you're like also
organizing a conference organizing an
event organizing a community you need to
prioritize having a committee at your
event
so okay you have a code of conduct you
found the perfect code of conduct but if
that doesn't get enforced then it
doesn't matter right because then people
complain and nothing happens it's like
when somebody says you can give me
feedback and they give you feedback and
then say and then you're like but I'm
not gonna use the feedback right so then
you don't give feedback
so for this then you also need to have a
clear process for enforcement that gets
defined
and it usually happens that again the
same like diversity code of conduct is
like an after thought in many situations
situations you know people think about
yeah we have it but then
it's not really prioritized
and again all of the stuff what I said
before
you need training
learnable stuff
you
and people who are in committees you
should expect that like if I see a
committee I know that a lot of people
have expectations that at least some of
the people in the committee have proper
training for code of conduct
and if you're asking yourself how do I
get in Code of Conduct communities well
this is really easy you volunteer
because this is like the part that as if
as it's an afterthought usually in many
places
people like really close to the event
they are scrambling for volunteers oh we
don't have a volunteer for the code of
conduct so this is perfect opportunity
the place where you will always find the
spot
last month we did a code of conduct
enforcement training with other
technology with sage so they're actually
the ones that are like I think at the
moment they
the most know-how about code of conduct
enforcement
and in this training
we learned like we discussed how to take
an incident report how to listen how to
respond to a reported person how to
evaluate the report how to collect the
data and preserve privacy at the same
time because you know you want to make a
safe space the code of conduct process
should be safe so I can totally
recommend this Enforcement Training and
any other training that sage has
and yeah this is my sketch note from the
event but you won't be able to read it
here so and so closing I have some
Community statements so one of them is
from Drew Drew is in the code of conduct
work group with the psf and he says I
want to help make it easier for
organizations to see why having a stroke
code of conduct enhances Community
rather than stifles
who you've seen keynoting
yesterday they say I would like to see
the code of conduct being used not just
for major incidents but also as a
mediation tool for small incidents
and small incidents
for a lot of us for for some people they
are not an incident for some people
they're like
borderline incident
those are like really hard to deal with
because you're like hmm
yeah I mean you know but this person is
doing a hundred borderline incidents per
month right so maybe it's not so
borderline and or but also small
incidents like microaggressions which
are also super ambiguous to deal with
and helping us in general like talk
about things and not just when the house
is burning
and think about it the future developers
so this is from GitHub
python Developers
a lot of them everywhere
our python Community is global
we need to understand that we truly need
to invest in learning
how to communicate with each other
you know we are not born communicators
like actually we don't know how to speak
when we're babies I heard
here anybody has babies they don't know
how to talk yet right so they learn
speaking one language you know another
language
I mean charge GPT is going to solve all
our problems but let's see and so yeah
so let's do this together improve our
communication culture in our communities
and that was it thank you for listening
to me and uh you can reach out to me
this is
um a quote from Jessica she's also in
the uh python software Foundation code
of conduct work group and did the
workshop and after that posted this
about it
so if you have any questions and or
disagreements or opinions
[Applause]
I do appreciate a lot your thoughts I
have a whole article written just for
taking notes I don't have questions in
slidos but I do have
um does anyone here would like to ask a
question
um yeah thank you for uh for your
interesting talk yeah it's a it's a big
topic obviously
would you maybe share I mean anonymously
of course some examples where you saw
that the reporting certain type of yeah
incidents really helped to to improve
the situation or like you've seen for
example the same person who was reported
that it was just different
[Music]
like what I'm trying to say
um maybe do you see real the the impact
of being having a code of conduct in
place like and in which areas
yes I think so I think one of the
one of the most visible things that we
also dealt with I think with it within
the psf and had a lot of discussions
about was the renaming of the master
Branch to Maine
also in Python
and they were very a lot of very upset
people
and but this also gave a platform for
people to say
to to be able to be told that they are
not right to be upset about like this is
not something in 2020 that you should be
on that front and I think there were
also some public statements made about
this on python other things I think
we sometimes get people reaching out
who did not have a report against them
but someone said you
foreign
so someone's they wrote something and
then someone said but you you this is
kind of like non-inclusive how you talk
to me according to the code of conduct
so somebody so sometimes people like
without reporting it but they use the
code of conduct in like a comment on
GitHub and
um then this person actually reached out
to us for us to explain
how what did they ever do wrong
you know so some people are open for
this dialogue so it gets you know like
it's it brings a little bit of
visibility that this there is a place
for this dialogue and it's moving some
people forward and in the end it was
like
hey you said this code is useless you
know so useless is a
when you read it it has a tone in your
head right so
um
and it's a lot of work for whoever reads
the sentence that something is useless
to not see it as
that tone right so so there's that of
course
um
sometimes in events
I think in events it's a little bit
written so a difference so in with the
python software Foundation we have like
uh written reports but with events you
need to act completely differently so if
something happens you need to
sometimes remove a person from a
conference
and that can make a big difference for a
lot of other people
so I don't know if you've ever noticed
that or been in a situation where you
had to be the somebody had to be removed
from a event
I mean by ladies it's always
sometimes something happens in the
meetups that are about with diverse
groups so I think
there we definitely need a code of
conduct to have some dialogues
no
um
we are kind of over time but I do have a
question about talking about the
language I have two kind of different
questions one is about
I have issues with the word enforcement
I have zero issues with that especially
because we are volunteer based and even
doing the training we're still in a
volunteer base do you have any thoughts
on that
yeah
so
I think this the word enforcement here
is not about that you're enforcing
something on somebody it's more about
the
process itself that
you're in order to make sure that the um
the process is fair for everybody
you need to follow some steps
like this is more like it's about how
you yes and it's a lot more work right
because instead of just having a
conversation on the hallway somebody
says something happened now you actually
have to write it down somewhere in a way
that it doesn't fall back to that person
getting
discriminated or something bad happens
to that so there's a lot of reasons why
it's import or even when you talk to the
person that got reported
you need to you know
have a specific language to give
feedback otherwise it can all
explode
so so this word enforcement is it sounds
very
harsh but it's just it's it's not about
like on enforcing it on people but it's
more about the fact that you kind of
have to follow a process
and not following a process in this case
can have a little bit of bad
repercussions to different people
thank you we are really anyone would
like to do some comment or share
something
so I appreciate a lot of our thoughts in
sharing your experience and thank you
all for participating
thank you